hello I'm dr. Sadler and this is another
installation of Sadler's honest reviews
and today I'm looking at another book
about stoicism aiming to introduce it to
a wider audience framing it in popular
terms it is called a better human the
stoic heart mind and soul by George Jay
Bradley came out in 2017 and this is a
little bit of a first for me in all of
my honest reviews up until this point I
have actually recommended to my viewers
that with it certain qualifications they
probably ought to consider purchasing
the works that I was reviewing
unfortunately in this case I can't
actually recommend this book except for
certain purposes or with certain
qualifications which we'll get to in a
bit
I always begin these reviews by talking
about three asses that is the style of
the work the structure of the work and
providing a kind of summary as well so
let's start with the last part the
summary you would think from the title a
better human the stoic heart mind and
soul that it's going to be very much
about transformation of the self by
means of the self using stoic philosophy
aiming at something like a stoic heart
mind and soul which are not originally
stoic distinctions but you can see how
that that's a popular way of looking at
it today we often put those those terms
together and distinguish them from each
other the book itself is I mean how to
put it it's really a self helpy sort of
book it's not an adequate introduction
to stoic philosophy or even practices as
such the author is on page 37 of the
work will say that they're gonna focus
on the Big Five stoic techniques
negative visualization self reflection
practicing poverty faking positivity and
forgiving yourself and that that really
is where a lot of the focus of the book
lies and as a matter of fact we can sort
of launch from that into structure so
the book is laid out in terms of three
main parts heart mind and soul and each
one has certain chapters connected with
it that you know in some respects at
least some of them do you have
connections with stoic philosophy so
there's six chapters in the heart part
one of which focus is on the dichotomy
of control very important
self-discipline the virtues a whole
section on fearlessness which really
could be rolled into the the virtues
finding opportunity and setbacks
hardwork should be actually there's a
typo here hard
work and perseverance which would also
be under in the classic stoic treatment
under fearlessness because courage
includes that then there's this mind
section which is a chapter on
decision-making a chapter on mentorship
which I should mention is kind of an
interesting idea there a chapter on
realism a chapter on agility a buzzword
common in business areas and I suppose
in self-help areas as well the third
part being authentic the past is
teachers sociability and gratefulness so
each has a chapter on these things and
what are you gonna find in these
chapters so it is kind of a mix of some
discussions of classic stoic perspective
practices philosophy in very very small
amounts largely called not out of actual
stoic text but summaries of them and
then a lot of examples a lot of
explanations many of which are you know
you could say stock examples at this
point you know talking about
Epictetus and Stockdale and Vietnam okay
that that's been done quite a lot or you
know talking about Mandela bringing up
Ben Franklin all those sorts of things
are quite common in this this sort of
literature the examples are you know aim
to illustrate the the ideas and it moves
back and forth from those I will say
something else about the structure of
the work and this has more to do with
just layout so if you look at it this
book could have been much shorter if it
was actually laid out that is edited in
such a way as to follow normal
conventions it's double spaced
throughout the entire thing there are
these massive indentations on the side
so this is a 300 page book which really
probably could have been about just
given proper paging and and and
structure and stuff like that maybe 150
ages total so what else do we have to
say about this the the writer really
enjoys using equations some of which are
taken from Duckworth's book on grit
which we'll talk about in a moment so
here's here's just some examples
agility plus fearlessness equals
creativity or a little bit earlier
fearlessness plus agility equals
creativity then there's also salt and
some multiplication as well in there if
you're into that sort of thing I guess
that could be helpful as a sort of a
reminder but it's you know it's it's as
mathematical as the stuff going on and
Jacques Lacan's works right it's not
math at all on page 37 the author talks
about there being five big practices
that he's gonna focus on in the work
negative visualization self reflection
practicing poverty faking positivity and
forgiving yourself and you know there's
lots of examples given and these come up
over and over again throughout the work
I will mention as well that the passages
and paraphrase is taken from the work
are largely from a small set of sources
two of which are arguably connected
well yes quite one of which is
definitely connected with stoicism one
of which is arguably connected with
stoicism the rest of which have only the
most tangential connections with it and
so he uses William Irvine stoicism a
guide to the good life he also relies on
Ryan holiday and you know also brings up
Tim Ferriss okay so that stuff you know
the further we get into like Ferriss the
less distinctively stoic it is and then
he draws a lot from Duckworth's book
grit and from green and fifty cents
forty nine laws book you know simply
saying that you're referencing stoicism
doesn't actually make it stoicism so you
got to be a little bit careful about
that and I'll say a little bit more
about that that issue of drawing heavily
on these different sources a little bit
later on so style structure summary
you've got the summary style is kind of
easy breezy it's you know it's supposed
to be for a popular audience and you
know there's it's not bad it's not great
it's certainly readable and you know
there's a few cases where the language
is you read it and you're like like for
example saying that Nero's court had a
Byzantine lifestyle the Byzantines come
of course much later than that and so in
some respects the the more literate a
reader you are the less you're going to
like this book because they're gonna be
these glaring points or you're like oh
that doesn't sound quite right but that
that gives you an idea about what you're
getting into with this work I will
mention as well there is no index it
simply ends on the last page with with a
bunch of summaries so that's not
particularly helpful in a work it's
always nice to have an index but this is
a self-published work so you can you can
kind of tell that that's that's going to
be the case that's about enough about
the 3 s's
so what are some key ideas from the work
itself a lot of it is as I said kind of
standard fare for this this popular
literature discussing stoicism I won't
call this actually a book on stoicism as
such because it's more tangential it
touches on stoicism and incorporates
some things but but it's not really a
stoic book as such the key idea is that
you will find in here are pretty much
the same as in other literature so for
example there's a lot of discussion
about negative visualization can be used
for this can be used for this here's how
you do it but that's an in pretty much
every book on stoicism out there for a
popular audience these days and the
notion of like sticking to things the
popular idea of forgiving yourself which
takes from Seneca but also from
contemporary literature I would say that
you know another thing you could say is
a key idea from the book that's
illustrated over and over again is that
famous people did or said things that in
some way connects up with stoic
philosophy and practices so I mentioned
you know for example Nelson Mandela
often talked about as being a stoic in
his his prison cell and you know looked
at as a great example of nothing against
Mandela but you know I think that he was
drawing on sort of a broad spectrum of
of things there's nothing absolutely
distinctively stoic about his approach
you know of course it talks about
Stockdale the at that time jet pilot now
Admiral who you know drew upon Epictetus
that's good stuff
Benjamin Franklin is a very popular
example because he talks about the
virtues and there's an attempt to try to
align the virtues that the Franklin
talks about with the stoic cardinal
virtues and you know the understanding
of those what else there's there some
interesting disguise
about goal-setting and practical
reasoning and the mind parts which does
make sense and I will say that there's
there's you know a few interesting parts
to it like the discussion about
mentorship or the past as as teacher so
those are all you know key ideas that
you're gonna get from it I suppose you
know chapter 2 is about discipline I
don't know that this is telling anybody
anything new that if you want to try to
transform yourself and your life and
your relationships you have to actually
work at it but I suppose if somebody
needs to hear that that that's a good
thing for them so that's that's some key
ideas in this work
I think perhaps the best thing that I
can say about this book in terms of
positive points is it's not a terrible
book it's you know it can be quite
useful I think as a you know if we're
gonna use the metaphor of gateway drug
getting people into stoicism I prefer
the the metaphor of a ladder that you
would climb and then leave behind you
know coming from Vic and Stein but also
other places as well could be a stepping
stone so you know those those are nice
things that you can say it does connect
stoicism it's a pop culture and two
examples that people might not have
thought of beforehand including you know
incidents from Bradley's own life so
that that's a good point about it there
are some useful discussions here and
there for example early on in the work
after talking about the dichotomy of
control it starts talking about
discipline of course he's taking this
from William Irvine but he says we you
know the idea is to be disciplined and
to do so in those areas like choosing
not to react to someone else's bad
decision where we have control we must
recognize where we have control and then
be disciplined in those areas in terms
of our own controllable actions so you
know he's connecting up concepts with
each other and that that's kind of nice
as well what else there's some decent
passages from stoic sources including
Epictetus and Marcus Aurelius and Seneca
and of course from William Irvine's book
so you know that's a plus you know you
could find for example he says here's
Epictetus talking about reframing and
talking the men are disturbed not by the
things which happened but by the
opinions about the things so you know if
you read through this book you are going
to get some some you know not
particularly organized but a good
smattering of stoic quotes that then you
can
think about more and go back to the
texts and read them within a context as
Seneca says you know stoicism is not
something to be taught through sound
bites and bullet points but rather is a
systematic doctrine so it could be
useful for for that I suppose
it's unfortunate but I do have a lot of
what we can view as negative points to
make about this book and I can't
recommend it except if nothing else is
available to learn about stoicism so we
may as well launch into them and you
know it in my view there's actually a
passage in this that really sums up what
what is wrong with this this book and
the approach that's taken it's it's
discussing this is in the gratefulness
section and he says that he thinks what
one of the best movies of all time is is
Fight Club now you know we can all
differ on aesthetic issues like that but
here's here's what he draws upon he says
that there's there's this scene right
where here we go the gas station manager
is taken hostage he puts a gun to the
gas station managers head
the narrator jack stands in the
background tyler durden looks berserk
and he thinks that that you know he's
gonna execute the gas station manager
then tyler durden starts getting
philosophical he asked Raymond what he
wants to be
Raymond confesses he's lost the urgency
over time but he dreamed of becoming a
veterinarian he takes his driver's
license and lets him go warning he'll be
checking up on him and if he hasn't
taken serious steps towards becoming a
vet he'll follow through with the
execution threat and then Durden says
tomorrow will be the most beautiful day
of Raymond K Hessel life his breakfast
will taste better than any meal you and
I have ever tasted and Jack then says
you had to give it to him he had a plan
so many of you have probably seen that
that scene somebody is terrorizing a gas
station clerk and you know waxing
philosophical about always giving them a
great opportunity now here's here's what
the book says this scene is pure
stoicism an absolute exercise in
negative visualization taken to its
extreme that's a terrible thing to say
and that seems to me sort of
a great example of what this book does
over and over again it engages with
stoic content but in a way that shows
that the author doesn't really
understand stoicism as a larger
philosophy and brings in pop culture in
ways that are going to somehow make a
connection and then muffs it so that's
part of what made reading this so so
disappointing I may as well get into
some of the other criticisms that I have
the organization heart mind and soul you
know there's something to organizing
things in that way I don't see how these
chapters actually fit into that you know
one of the things you could do is just
jumble them around and put any of them
anywhere you wanted there isn't really a
great sequential systematic structure to
it they're just kind of thrown in there
there's just categories boxes to place
things in you could have called it a B
and C you could have he could have you
know flipped it under the desires the
the the three toll boy if he wanted to
it doesn't matter because none of this
actually is laid out in a systematic
fashion the book you know again for for
a literate reader is going to irritate
you because it begins with some fake
history and it continues that on through
so when you're when you're reading it
you're like oh come on dude what is what
is wrong with this this sort of idea so
he tells us you know for example with
the possible exception of certain
schools of Buddhism most systems of
thought aim only to teach people how to
live well in this world as and as a
byproduct of a larger moralistic program
etc etc right and then he says we should
do these things because God or God or
the gods decreed it to be so or if we
don't believe in gods we should apply
enlightened rationale to our behavior
and none of this teaches us how to be
better humans now in this life or how to
be the best humans we possibly can be
but one group of thinkers did lay out a
prescription for how to lead a life that
produces success and enjoyment
it of life in the here and now of course
the Stoics now it's a nice thing to say
that the Stoics did in fact provide us
with a great blueprint but man ancient
philosophy that were the Stoics the only
people concerned with the good life and
transformative practices I mean there's
this guy Aristotle and he actually
talked quite a lot about that
the Stoics rival school the Epicureans
they also focused on that you know I
mean this is this is really like
embarrassingly bad history of philosophy
and you know it jumping ahead so here's
on page 137 there's a howler about Plato
right he's saying stoic principles
aren't composed of esoteric theory
instead they're underpinned with really
solid and well tested practical
philosophy in fact that was the whole
point of stoicism to get away from ideas
that had become ever more convoluted and
divorced from everyday life
beautiful ideas for sure like Plato's
ideal forms but ones that didn't really
do all that much to help us live better
lives in the here and now that is like
again only somebody who doesn't know
anything about ancient philosophy could
could write that because I mean middle
platonism Plutarch write all about how
to live the great life this the early
Stoics had extremely convoluted thought
and systems and an ax cursory reading of
the better secondary literature on
stoicism let alone just going to Cicero
would let the you know the writer know
that that's the case so clearly we're
dealing with somebody who's study of
stoicism is quite shallow and and it
shows you know it doesn't go don't go
far enough with the passages that are
provided there again not a surprise so
there's really a lot of missed
opportunities to take where some classic
stoic ideas like the dichotomy of
control or the four virtues or placing
yourself before you know the the eyes of
the sage or somebody like that these
could be worked through and there
just sort of like you know the
opportunities are dropped so that that's
really kind of an issue one example of
how the book kind of goes wrong is its
discussion of negative visualization
now- visually visualization understood
in a couple different ways and this is a
fairly recent term for the practice you
know that this guy got it from William
Irvine right or maybe from from Ryan
holiday or Tim Ferriss it's not talked
about as such as negative visualization
in classic store text instead there's a
number of different passages where
Seneca Marcus Aurelius
Epictetus and others discuss how you you
you know visualize or imagine or bring
before the eyes something bad that could
be happening as a regular practice it's
not a sort of everything and the kitchen
sink practice the way it's made out to
be in this book where negative he just
basically uses the term negative
visualization and a lot of points to try
to connect things together whether it is
negative visualization or not you know
so that that that's kind of a stand-in
for some of the problems with this
it certainly doesn't go far enough with
the discussions of practical reasoning
or prioritization instead what we see is
circling around the same themes and this
makes the book at very repetitive very
quickly because you're like oh you know
if you haven't heard all this stuff
already you're like yeah okay I I see
where you're going with this you you're
seeing this as connecting everything
together for me this is just one more
repetition of using this term or this
concept and at a number of points he
will take quotes from famous people and
then he won't actually source them so
there's a Nietzsche quote for example in
here and what's the source for it
Duckworth's book on grit not for all you
know human all too human which he should
have provided and that's you know an
example of not doing the scholarship
that would go into just the basic stuff
for four
work and that leads me to probably my
biggest complaint about the book it's
really much more of a stringing together
ideas some of which are coming from
stoic thinkers many of which are not
coming from Stoics at all they're taken
from holidays work which is halfway
stoic I'd say but half way other stuff
right there's a lot of things in there
that are not remotely connected with
stoicism from Duckworth's grits which
you know it's it's not a bad book but
it's not a good book either there's a
lot of stuff coming in here from the
laws of power by Green and $0.50 again
you know every time I read that I'm like
what is this guy thinking and and you
know from from other sources as well
within you you might call it the popular
literature and and you know if the stuff
was actually well thought through and
critically examined and systematically
discussed I think you could do something
with that but that's not happening in
this book it's just sort of like
throwing things together seeing what
sticks and then going from from there so
I I found all of those aspects of this
book rather problematic
so unfortunately my last word on this
book is that I don't recommend it for
readers it certainly is not worth the
price that I see being charged for it on
Amazon it doesn't live up to the very
interesting program of helping people to
become a better human except
accidentally in the same way that if
somebody is trying to lose weight
basically any diet will help you to lose
weight because there's some sort of
structure to it but you're not going to
be able to follow through and make any
real progress I mean if you've never
read anything about the Stoics and
you're really attracted to you know 50
cent and Robert Greene and that sort of
you know popular productivity / learning
how to life hack your way through things
okay this this could be okay for you but
I I think that most readers would
probably do way better to skip this and
I mean if you want popular literature on
stoicism there are many good books out
there that I've recommended myself this
unfortunately isn't isn't one of them so
I have to give it the thumbs down and
that's the end of my review
you